what's going on guys this is rob and we
need to talk about
gore the god butcher and here's the
reason why
word has reached my ears that people are
angry
because gore the god butcher
has a nose
and doesn't have tentacles on his head
now
barring their weird fetish when it comes
to tentacles i can understand to a
degree that like he's not exactly comic
book accurate i grew out of that years
ago right like years ago i i grew beyond
this idea that the characters have to be
comic book accurate i just love seeing
them on the silver screen but here's the
thing man
who cares
no one cares it doesn't matter there's
not going to be a moment in this movie
there's not going to be a time when thor
and gore are fighting for the first time
and gore beats the hell out of him and
i'll tell you exactly how i know that's
going to happen here in a minute but
there's not going to be a moment in that
fight scene when anyone is sitting in
the movie theater and it's like god this
fight seems amazing but you know what
would make it better if gore didn't have
a nose and had tentacles on his head no
one's gonna be saying that right no
one's gonna be writing a review for the
new york times and saying yeah man thor
god of thunder phenomenal movie the
characters it was great seeing it all
happen thor teaming up with the
guardians of the galaxy i loved seeing
him in his ravager outfit gore is one of
the most amazing and intriguing villains
the mcu has introduced so far
but he really should have not had a nose
and had tentacles on his head no one's
gonna be saying that right if you are
angry about this it's because you're
looking for a reason to be mad that's
literally the only reason anybody would
be pissed off about this the kind of
people who are angry about this are the
kind of people who go to a movie theater
and buy a movie ticket and they get an
assigned seat which is all the way back
in the left-hand corner with the view
that sucks and the sound quality is
absolute garbage and they get into the
theater and the movie starts and they
realize there's no one in that theater
but they stay there anyway because
that's their assigned seat and that's
where they're supposed to sit right like
people who can't think outside the box
like most all reasonable human beings
would just move to the middle of the
movie theater where you get the best
view and you get the best sound but
these kind of people would not let me
tell you something man what what really
matters when it comes to this is not
tentacles and a lack of a nose right
we're not trying to turn gore the god
butcher into voldemort like what like
like the guy doesn't need to be 100
comic book accurate what matters here
and the comic book accuracy that needs
to happen in this movie is gore beating
the hell out of thor let me tell you
something man the first time these two
fought gorgeous straight up clapped
clapped them cheeks son
just them cheeks i mean just just
clapping them cheeks right and we're not
talking about like black bold getting
his cheeks clapped by wanda because
black bolt sucks we're talking about
just just clapping sun i mean just
clapping those cheeks it was amazing to
watch that happen man i mean just just
man it was a beating and thor did what
he could right but gore the god butcher
was like man son you better come strong
like literally just took it to him
stabbed him beat him with an inch of his
life right thor's just like thor's
standing there in the face of gore i all
swole up just knots and and bruises all
over i mean
guy's head looks like a character from a
from a a bugs bunny cartoon right does
all them taps on his head right it's
just lumps divots right guy looked like
a golf course so so the guys getting guy
got absolutely crushed right absolutely
destroyed calls down the thunder injures
gore gore has to retreat had he not done
that thor would have been a dead man
right now here's the here's here's the
craziness of it right it was one thing
to see gore just absolutely just wrecked
thor it was another to see him wreck
three thor's
at the same time son that's what gore
did man it was absolutely nuts like
quite literally right it's one of the
craziest things quite literally there is
a point in this comic when you get or at
least in the storyline you get thor from
the past who couldn't lift millionaire
he was the one that initially fought
gore and just just
just just got got those got those cheeks
clapped right clapping like clapping
like like he's clapping for a high
school basketball team right just
clapping
clapping them cheeks right just getting
absolutely crushed then you had thor
from the present day right who did have
the power to lift or had the ability to
left mjolnir then you had thor in the
far flung future right all father thor
with the power of the odin force
they all just got absolutely crushed by
by gore just absolutely crushed by this
guy it took present-day thor
wielding two hammers right two mjolnirs
and the all-black necro sword to defeat
gore and even then he couldn't fully
defeat him but it was crazy man it was
absolutely nuts that kind of stuff needs
to be comic book accurate right maybe
not necessarily the whole you know thor
in the future and throwing the president
and all that kind of stuff but i can
tell you this man you're probably gonna
see jane foster thor team up with odin's
son to face off against gore and he's
gonna he's gonna wreck him both he's
gonna absolutely crush them both like
you're you're literally gonna watch that
fight she's gonna be like man these guys
never even had a chance and it was like
nope right like this this ain't karate
kid son right gore swept that leg and it
was curtains like that's all it was man
drapes
drapes
that's that's literally all it was but
that needs to that's that's what needs
to become a big accurate in this movie
now here's the other thing too right
gore is being played by christian bale
this guy is legitimately one of the
single greatest actors to ever exist in
hollywood like quite literally the guy's
phenomenal devotes himself entirely to
the character now i'm not saying that
christian bale basically hid away from
the sun for five years or to give
himself that pale skin i'm just saying
christian pale is an amazing actor and
to see him play this character of gore
oh it's going to be absolutely
phenomenal the one thing that i don't
want because i don't care about a nose
and tentacles the one thing that i don't
want that i don't want to see in this
movie i don't want to see them send gore
the god butcher the way they normally do
when it comes to villains right like
gord the god butcher has some cool
moments and then with the power of hope
and the plot itself jane foster and
odin's son managed to defeat gore i
don't want to see that man this is
legitimately one of those movies where i
kind of want to see the bad guy win i'm
going to be honest with you guys i love
the character of gore that much right
just just the development was absolutely
phenomenal i mean that that villain was
cool it's one of those funny things at
no point did his nose or his lack of
nose and and tentacles on his head have
anything to do with his character
development right i am gore the source
of my power
is my tentacles nobody's that that's not
the case right that's that's not the
case right so again like i'm excited for
this movie man i am hyped for this movie
more so because i'm ready to just watch
thor get crushed and i don't mean like
crush like you know well he fights a
good fight and like some stuff happens
no i mean like just watch thor get
wrecked in a way that we've never seen
thor get wrecked before just get
absolutely crushed because here's the
thing that has that the marvel cinematic
universe has to establish here right
it's one of the most important things
they have to establish we've seen thor
in some cool fights it would have been
more interesting if we'd seen thor face
off against like thanos right like the
way the incredible hulk did and get
wrecked by thanos but what they have to
establish here is that thor can be
readily beaten by people out there who
are just more capable than he is for a
variety of different reasons and i'm not
talking about like you know thanos and
his forces overpowering thor and loki on
their ship no i'm just talking about one
guy who's just on a crusade to kill gods
and that's it right literally the guy's
just the guy's just petty as hell he's
got a vendetta and it's just like gods
have to die and that's the end of it
right like that's literally the end of
it and there's nothing more to it than
that it has to just be something that
simple not some guy like thanos who is
on a whole different level because
here's the thing gore by himself you
take away the necro sword gore is just a
dude right he's just like a guy who's
pissed off at the world he's like every
15 year old ever right just young full
of angst smoking cigarettes to listen to
the cure mad because the girl he likes
in biology class doesn't like him back
right that's basically what he is right
at the end of the day i mean not the
whole girl biology class but like that's
basically the whole thing granted he's
got a legitimate beef right the guy
comes from a world where he lost his
whole family right and the gods that
they pray to just ignore them all the
time so the guy's got a legitimate
reason to be upset but without having
the necro sword dude's got nothing right
he's like people on twitter he's just
got harsh language and nothing else but
you put that necro sword in his hands
son man you better believe he's going to
take you for a ride on the pain train
and that's exactly what he does that's
exactly what he does but having somebody
like that with thanos it was a whole
different kettle of beans right we all
knew just but you know as a comic book
reader or any number of things you knew
that like thanos just by himself without
the infinity gauntlet was enough to just
absolutely wreck the incredible hulk or
thor or any of those guys gore is not
and the guy even looks small right like
you you look at him in the trailer and
it's just like damn this dude's tiny man
like good god gorilla
eat something son like that go to the
gym lift some weights put some muscle on
like something along those lines but you
put that necro sword in his hand it's
drapes it's curtains and i'm excited to
see how that unfolds right so with that
being said guys you know here's the
thing i also want to do a video on jane
foster at some point because i love jane
foster thor and people are kind of
pissed off about jane foster thor and i
don't understand why because i feel like
they're just looking for a reason to be
angry too but i love jane foster thor
man i've always loved jane foster thor
and i'll tell you right now i think jane
foster is a more interesting thor than
thor was right then odin's son was like
the only like like she had great
character development and she had great
stories and she did some awesome stuff
now she's a valkyrie quite literally
marvel just shoved her off to the
cornfields and just like you go to the
corn fields because nobody likes you
anymore right you're not thor and nobody
cares about jane foster when she's just
a nurse in a hospital somewhere so like
you go do your thing but they'll
probably end up killing her off at the
end of this movie to be honest you know
they'll probably just end up writing her
out that'll be the end of jane i think
thor is gonna die too to be honest like
i think this will be the end of odin's
son i don't know if that's gonna be the
case or not but regardless i'm excited
to see gore right so stop being pissed
off over things that don't matter enjoy
the ride and when you get into the movie
theater just remember once you walk out
ask yourself the question at what point
did you ever say the fight between thor
and gore would have been better if gore
had a nose or didn't have a nose and had
tentacles on his face or on his head
right like if if you don't find yourself
asking i guess if you do find yourself
asking the question okay cool i guess
kudos to you whatever but if you don't
find yourself asking that question
exactly i was right no one cares it
doesn't matter so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i'll
catch you all later
peace